olanra for yummy i'm andrea foo and I
Meganium we're from conception della
required Argentina we want to get to
know Nuremberg as it is much to offer
it's a pretty suited it's rich in
history behind us is the Kaiser Bagh
castle come with us oh let's go wait in
yen cool [ __ ] look yeah it's the zine
bell tower lasting Delta in below 100 12
113 we made it what of you owe me like
ad
but in the roofs Argentina only has
rooms like this in the south where
there's snow it's all very nice is what
Apple any area though waiting oh what a
great view we have to take a picture all
right uh what should we do now no let's
see what nuran back has to offer won't
you mama turn back here we come get
indirect that's the old city hall yeah I
got it said to how is an old underground
prison let's go in Ethan apparently the
people weren't very tall good for you
it's freezing in here come on that you
must be brave we're entering the torture
chamber we prefer manacles but I'm not
going now goodbye ok ok do it earlier
that was innocent we're at the
Documentation Center on the Nazi Party
rally grounds an important place let's
go in
so see me whenever they feel I'm very
moved by the history of what happened
here what's on display here really moves
me ki importante it's very important for
Germany to heal the wounds of history to
face up to and come to terms with its
past at this documentation center they
deal with this history part of the
notorious keep for Bigfoot that wasn't
powerful you're right let's head back to
the city no but it's
but I thought the nameless behind us is
the deutsche bahn transport museum let's
take a look
yes my first class car look at that
detail me down this was Germany's
fastest locomotive before World War one
it could go 150 kilometers an hour windy
weather genome interpreter yah yah midi
2.2 meters in diameter amazing
oh yeah cool our day here was phenomenal
the transport museum was really
interested nürnberg has much to discover
but it's time to say goodbye